last year mark Greene was the Democratic
nominee for mayor of New York selling
out is his new book to crying the
influence of money on politics he spoke
at the Columbia political union for
about an hour and 15 minutes thank you
all again for coming I hope you enjoy
the program it is with great pleasure
that I introduce to you mark Greene
Thank You Alana thank you for contacting
my daughter who contacted me and for
having the Columbia political union
bring me here at one of the two best
most expensive colleges in New York
State and as the father of two Cornell
students you'll allow me that privilege
to say that you could be in worse
company America has um I've been talking
about because the president has been
talking about the axis of evil North
Korea Iraq I'd like to speak tonight
instead about the evil of access by big
oil by big tobacco how do you know when
a democracy is in decline now when the
plane crashes um you know it when a
bridge collapses so too does the
reputation of its engineer but what
about a democracy when that loses
altitude or approaches a catastrophe
it's more like a bather in water getting
slowly but increasingly hot by the time
you realize the problem it's too late so
how do you know when a democracy has
gone from warm to being scalded I would
maintain its when one senator and one
mayor spent as much in America getting
elected as all the legislative
candidates for Parliament and Great
Britain combined it's when the average
candidate for US Senate in our ten
largest states have to raise 34
thousand dollars a week every year for
six years in order to win office it's
when point one percent of Americans
contribute more and have a bigger say
and sway then the ninety-nine point nine
percent who don't give a thousand
dollars it's when the cost of running
for Senate and Congress has increased in
the last 25 years not ten percent not a
hundred percent but tenfold a thousand
percent or an after-tax thought or an
after inflation dollars threefold in
real dollars in ten years it's when it's
harder for the average working person in
this country to get elected to the
American Congress then the equivalent to
get elected to the russian congress it's
when interest legislatively interested
political action committee money go 721
for incumbents guess what ninety-eight
percent of House members win ninety-nine
percent Kremlin like rates of success
when legislative office in new york
state and around the country on average
ninety-four percent of the time the
bigger spender wins so if you're
spending less than someone else you
could win you could win lotto you could
win in Las Vegas six out of a hundred
times the lesser spender wins all other
things being equal ninety-four percent
of the time they lose and it's when
other Western democracies have seventy
and eighty percent turnout in their
elections whereas in america the world's
oldest proudest democracy for good
reason only half turned out in
presidential elections a third turnout
and off your congressional elections
like we're about to have in a week and
about on average fifteen percent one in
seven turnout in primary elections come
what is a democracy vaclav havel the
poet president of the former czech
republic said it's sort of like a
distant horizon that you can
an approach but never reach that's a
good definition we can never have a pure
democracy still Laurens Goodwin who
wrote about the populists era at the
turn of the last century said democracy
at the very minimum here Republicans
Democrats greens independence would
agree is when you participate in the
government that has control over you
that can tax you that can conscript you
that can force you to serve on juries
for example but is it a democracy if 0.1
percent pays the piper if 80% stay home
or 85% stay home in primary elections or
f in the state we're in New York state
of the last two thousand legislative
campaigns in New York State over 25
years 25 incumbents over 25 years and
2000 elections under 1% lost re-election
in other words you've read a lot to have
earned your way into this extraordinary
University all the lessons you learned
about our textbook system of checks and
balances has evolved into a system
instead of checks more checks more
checks some cash the the ranting of
Warren Beatty and Bulworth is about
money and politics is frankly however
exaggerated theatrical more accurate
about the system than the all the fourth
of July speeches on the hustings that
you might hear what Mark Twain said of
bourbon is true of candidates too much
is not enough when it comes to money
well I put yourself in a candidate
choose hmmm because so many people to
press the public donors judging
candidacy by its Treasury and because
you can't know whether the other guy or
gal is going to spend the same as you or
more than you they kind of don't talk to
you a rational candidate feels coerced
into reenacting
the american-soviet arms race where it
wasn't enough to destroy the world once
over you had to engage in overkill
because too much was not enough and then
when the Supreme Court in the 1976 case
of Buckley v Valeo one of the two
stupidest Supreme Court decisions of the
last century Hardwick V Georgia
criminalizing private sexual conduct
among consenting same-sex adults was the
other invite me back for a conversation
about that once the supreme court said
that states and cities could not impose
a spending limit on candidates because
money was speech I thought money was
property I mean we all know that money
talks I thought that was the problem not
the explanation in fact money doesn't
talk money shouts and because of that
decision the arms race the arms race a
LMS took off and now the sky's the limit
thank you for coming I'm impressed
because to a lot of people the saga and
problem of money in politics is an old
one and people are weary about a
Plutarch complained about money
corrupting the Roman Senate it was
George Washington won his first race for
the house of burgess in Virginia in 1758
by engaging in what then was legal it's
called treating it's where you bought
liquor / voter and because he had enough
money he can't make this up we're on
c-span so I can't fool around he bought
a pint and a quart and a half of liquor
/ voter while he was away in the army he
won his first election and the rest is
history at the turn of the last century
it was set of standard oil but they did
everything to the Pennsylvania
legislature except refine it boys
penrose was a 300-pound Republican
senator in the early 1900s he once
candidly told a group of his donors rich
businessmen
you contribute to me so I can enact laws
which enhance your profits out of which
you can then give me yet more money
which is a great system for the
recipient for the donor except for the
people who were not in the room giving
and getting moved to Richard Nixon's two
million dollar shakedown of the milk
industry in 1972 after which milk price
supports and milk prices shot up finally
charles keating the head of a failed SNL
in the 1980s famously was asked did you
give all this money to the five centers
and what was famously called the Keating
five because you wanted to influence
them and were they influenced and
usually donors like this engage in a
whole variety of euphemisms he said I
certainly hope so Thank You boys Penrose
thank you Charles Keating for your
candor so money in politics has become a
little bit like sex in Victorian England
it's gossiped about it's giggled about
it's a disgust but it doesn't really
have a big impact because the public
eventually says a pox on both your
houses everybody does it allow me to be
skeptical about cynicism while money has
long been the lifeblood of American
politics only recently hasn't
metastasized to become a cancer due to
its volume and its impact between
nineteen seventy six and two thousand I
alluded to this before the average cost
of winning a House seat went from eighty
seven thousand dollars to eight hundred
and forty-two thousand dollars the
average cost of winning a US Senate seat
when from six hundred nine thousand
dollars in 1976 to 7.2 million dollars a
tenfold increase on the most money ever
spent in American history outside the
presidency for a campaign the New York
Senate race Hillary Clinton Rick Lazio
80 million dollars people thought 80
million dollars for
one Senate seat the record was broken in
2001 I ran a pauper a barefoot pop
billionaire named Michael Bloomberg ran
and because he spent seventy four
million dollars in one city the
equivalent of what George W Bush spent
winning the Republican nomination in 50
states the record of 80 million dollars
broken one year later in New York City
well collectively we spend 107 million
dollars the record is about to be broken
again what is it about New York the new
york gubernatorial race which has
another billionaire running as a
third-party candidate will end up the
candidates spending about 120 million
dollars hence when i say it's
metastasized it is not poetic license it
is quantitatively true and so although
understandably issues of terrorism and
social security and prescription drug
prices absorb the public in the
headlines i would argue that the scandal
of strings attached money corrupting
campaigns and government in our
democracy is the most urgent domestic
problem in america today because it
affects every other problem how can we
have an accessible affordable healthcare
the right sized and cost effective
military environmental health if HMOs
and arms contractors and polluters in
effect have a hammerlock over the
congressional committees or state
committees that pass on legislation in
the first place how can we adequately
fund education and child care if big
interests because of strings attached
money when the kind of breaks and
loopholes and bailouts that reduce the
public revenue so we don't have enough
money to lower class size and pay
teachers more and how can we attract the
best people on if to run and serve if
increasingly either special interest
hustlers or self-financing
multimillionaires wind
in the last decade three authors have
written more trenchant ly about politics
than James Madison are brilliant fourth
president and the author of so much of
the Federalist Papers a Charles
lindbloom man core Olson Bill grider the
latter now writes for the nation
magazine wrote books where they said
that while while Madison wrote famously
in federalist 10 that the good news is
that everybody on in the further the
First Amendment can compete countervail
each other so all voices are heard these
three modern authors understood that
some are more equal than others and that
if you spend more money in the
marketplace of politics it's a thumb on
the scale of decision now because
government accounts for a quarter of the
economy taxes people makes life and
death decisions do we go to war with
Iraq do we go back to conscription
clearly companies and citizens can
register vote and contribute money that
is their right what isn't right is that
the present campaign finance rules get
producers so much more access in power
than consumers gives organized interests
so much more power and access than
unorganized voters economist understand
it and call it the free rider effect
when you can benefit from the group's
acts without having to join the group
are often this leads to there's no
homeless pack there's no pack for poor
people there's no consumers pack but it
leads to auto companies having more
oomph over the cafe standards for
corporate average fuel efficiency auto
fuel standards than car buyers and why
coal producers had so much more leverage
over President Bush when as a candidate
he said that he would clamp down on
carbon dioxide emissions from the
Midwest but his president he did a 180
and the producers had a lot more say in
switching that decision than the
families and farmers who live downwind
of polluting plants so it's fine to be
rich it's fine to seek to be rich it's
fine for business people in the private
sector to make multi millions of dollars
to buy other companies but should we
allow unlimited private sector wealth to
leech into the public sector where money
buys not companies but congressman or
where money enables someone to run and
become a congressman or woman a key
benefit of a complementary systems of
democracy and capitalism is that each
needs the other is survive and thrive
and so capitalism is a brilliant
mobilizer of resources allocating wealth
but imperfectly some people without
skill or having bad luck but otherwise
starve or not go to school and so you
have democracy policing the marketplace
insisting on securities and exchange
laws any trust laws environmental laws
giving food stamps to the hungry and the
two balance each other what happens
though when the private sector makes a
hostile bid to take over the public
sector when the capitalist sector tries
to take over the Democratic small D
sector when elephant stands with the
chickens you know the result so the mo
the role of money in our democracy is a
quite a complicated one you're allowed
to spend money but if a few people spend
a lot of money they can overwhelm the
voice of everyone else to understand how
to draw the line in how to draft
campaign finance rules in my book
selling out if I had done it earlier I
might have won the election but I
decided to write a book about selling
out after the mayoral election because
while there are brilliant scholars who
have written about money in politics and
candidates who have raised millions of
dollars I realized after the mayoral
election not that many people had both
and written about raising big money and
raised big money in politics since I've
seen both sides from writing who runs
Congress with Ralph Nader 30 years ago
to running for mayor against the first
hundred dollar of vote candidate in
American history I realized the irony 30
years ago I right who runs Congress
saying too often money controls
elections 30 years later someone spent
seventy four million dollars in a city
to beat me does God have a sense of
humor or what here are the costs of the
current system for a special interests
have special access there is a beautiful
unspoken mutual shakedown that occurs
and imagine you are flying on the wall
of an honorable Congresspersons office
what happens is a lobbyist walks in and
says we really need your vote on this
one what does that mean that's a very
nice career you have there mr.
congressman I hope nothing happens to it
and the congressman says gee I'd love to
hear your point of view on this mr.
lobbyist and I hope we can work together
what that means is it's a very nice
company you have there mr. lobbyist I
hope nothing happens to it it is a
updated version of the boys penrose a
conversation I have a friend who's a
Democrat and a lobbyist in Washington as
I was researching selling out he said to
me quote when a major lobbyist seeks a
meeting with a member within a few weeks
they'll get an invitation to the members
next fundraiser if the lobbyist gives
he'll get another meeting if he doesn't
he won't and anybody who doesn't know
that shouldn't be hard to be a lobbyist
closed quote one congressperson said to
me look I had an interest group give a
twenty-five-thousand-dollar soft money
contribution that is it wasn't to the
candidate but it was to the party which
spent the money helping the candidate so
de facto hose to the candidate I own a
twenty-five-thousand-dollar Ford
Explorer he said to me when someone
hands me a twenty-five-thousand-dollar
contribution in effect well they're not
buying access but they're giving me the
equivalent of a car they've got my
attention
kind of think in the future it's rude of
me not to take their call immediately
the next time they call Barney Frank the
extremely eloquent smarter and he'll
Democrat from Massachusetts said we're
the only people on the planet expected
to receive large amounts of money from
people and not let it affect our
behavior one western United States
Senator said to me again off the record
see they all know how corrupt the system
is privately they all admit it when
they've left office but while they're in
office it's all the emperor has no
clothes they all say oh no no no no
money has no influence how dare you
criticize me for taking money and imply
that that would affect my vote but
privately the senator said we don't talk
much about the influence of money in the
Senate but senators are human
calculators who can weigh how much money
every vote will cost or gain them so the
access that money buys of course does
not guarantee legislative success I'm
not saying that but the lack of it
probably guarantees failure and when you
hear people say oh money just buys
access Wow without the access you can't
succeed you're not even in the game it's
like anybody can play in the major
leagues but it requires ten thousand
dollars to buy a ticket to get on the
field but without getting on the field
you can't play in the World Series so
after nine eleven to take a concrete
legislative example I would have thought
that many legislators would have better
understood the argument of not being
dependent on foreign oil and what the
cost of energy and efficiency was
because of our dependence on foreign oil
which could lead to us being indebted in
ways that was unhealthy for our country
so senators John Kerry Democrat and John
McCain Republican of Massachusetts in
Arizona respectively introduced
legislation to tighten of the auto fuel
efficiency standards so cars got more
miles per gallon and it reduced our
reliance on Middle East oil in general
and
Iraq in particular McCain told me he was
and he's no rube he was stunned when
they lost 62 to 38 and another senator
said it was a quote the most politically
cowardly thing I ever saw in the Senate
it was shameful it was money related
because Detroit mobilized there a couple
of hundred lobbyists and had a greater
say than the 250 million of 200 million
americans who own and drive cars one
more example Philip Morris in Texas
wrote a memo that became public and is a
very good guy in Texas named John sharp
who i believe is currently running for
lieutenant governor at the time he was
running for I believe State Controller
and Phillip marzin with the hope would
be a private memo wrote all right let's
get a lot of money to Texas Comptroller
candidate John sharp the plan i'm
quoting is to give early and large
contributions to sharp at the very least
buying sharps silence when it comes to
taxing us buying sharps silence he's
innocent they wrote about him without
his ok but what does that mean next
fundraising is at time thief as opposed
I told you that someone had kidnapped
all candidates for Senate and House on a
given day and held them hostage for 12
hours the story would be bigger than
Gary Condit it would there is such a
culprit it's called the current private
financing of congressional elections
because every candidate in in a
competitive Senate or house race has to
spend unless they're multimillionaires
six hours a day fundraising to stay in
office and so we pay our officials a fee
a salary to do the public's business but
half the time they're running into
cubicles in Washington with a an aide
puts out calls and they receive calls
and then he runs she runs back from
phone messages
just like a professional athlete would
not be as effective if he or she lost
half their training time so to an
elected official cannot be as effective
if half their time is spent not reading
not legislating not meeting constituents
but merely raising money a Senator
Robert Byrd who was the majority leader
of the Senate said that his body had
turned into part-time legislators and
full-time fundraisers images of bill
murray in groundhog day come to mind you
wake up and every day is you feel
trapped in the same cycle I speak as
someone who made 30,000 phone calls
running for mayor of New York over two
years that's not a typo 30,000 phone
calls because the only way to raise the
millions necessary to feed the monster
call TV advertising and broadcasting is
to raise it from people of like mind
Bill Clinton is quoted in one of the
Woodward books as saying as bellowing to
his staff I can think all you have me
doing all day is going to fundraising
events third perhaps worst of all the
money primary weeds out good women and
men of talent a judge Jase Kelly right
called such people the silent casualties
of our current system I know a man who's
famous a very smart and idealistic loves
public service when chuck schumer
running for senate i running for mayor
explained to him separately what it
takes he said I'm never going to run for
high office because the grind weeds out
good people who just would rather do
something more substantive than
telephonic um and by the way if you
don't win the money primary you know
I've never even get to the voters a
primary had so many public officials
when they leave office not only do
people not seek office but originally
senator Lautenberg and Senator Tom
Eagleton Charles
mathias sam nunn fred thompson were
recently complained that among the
reasons they're leaving is they can bear
remember the thirty four thousand
dollars a week to win senate in the 10
most popular states by the way when i
was 41 and had brown hair and wednesday
he got an underdog was a non dog i ran
for the US Senate in new york in 1986
and i won the democratic primary and
then lost to the incumbent al d'amato
and when i first visited the democratic
state chair he said mark very nice
record like your energy where's your
five million dollars up front and I went
I I had it when I left the office I
can't believe this I really apologize he
didn't laugh I thought you know the best
I had at that moment um this pay to play
system really hurts Democratic
candidates the most you see many not all
but most Republican aspirants oppose new
regulations and taxes out of authentic
belief so they regard the special
interest funding of public elections as
a brilliant system for them our
principles and payment go hand in hand
not so Democrats who if they start
getting the reputation of being
anti-business what that means is you
want strong environmental controls so
your children don't get asthma which
means you want to spend more for smaller
class size who your kids are
well-educated which means you're a big
spender if you're a Democrat um there's
a problem because the following will
happen Anthony hundreds of times you're
now running for office you're on the
phone hi mr. X John Smith love your help
III think I can win the house seat the
assembly seat the mayor's office very
nice mr. Smith where are you on X and X
is an issue that substantially affects
the donors bottom line so you say to
yourself oh my god my answer now will
determine whether they give the money I
need and when the choice is
oblivion or big oil some people might
choose big oil and so you know if you
say gee I'm really interested in X and
I'd like to hear more about it you know
no one else is listening the taxpayers
will have to pay the cost of X in the
future don't know you're making this
having this conversation won't blame you
if the money is spent later not on more
housing but on exes interest this
conversation happens thousands of times
a day in the election season and it
tilts the whole process Bob rice who
just ran for governor of Massachusetts
the prolific author an economist wrote
that he thinks his Democratic Party is
losing its identity to be a champion of
the average family because quote
Democrats become dependent on the rich
to finance their campaigns it's a little
difficult to represent the little fellow
when the big fellow pays the tab close
quote and and finally wealth can in
effect by office now wealthy
self-financed candidates will say nobody
owns me as Tom Golisano in New York
State now is saying as he runs for
governor or it's my money or I need to
spend so much to get known and that's
all true taken alone this reminds me of
the observation of the late Senator
Warren Magnuson of Washington State who
said quote all anybody wants in life is
an unfair advantage close quote yeah
look there can be great public servants
who happen to be wealthy John Kennedy
Franklin Roosevelt clearly wealth either
inherited or earned cannot be
disqualifying and I frankly think that
Jon Corzine in New Jersey the center and
Michael Bloomberg in New York are smart
effective and by and large successful
incumbents but as more multimillionaires
run and win and serve and the percentage
of them in the Senate has exceeded a
third which is about where it was before
the popular election of senators in 1913
we're going back to the future at a time
where wealthy men basically bought
Senate offices I mean almost literally
hence popular elections of senators not
by legislatures and we're in effect
going back to that system here are the
problems first again a wealth test
screens out quality candidates who are
experienced rich but cash poor and the
trend is increasing we've now had three
billionaire's running one year Michael
Bloomberg Tony Sanchez this is beyond
party Tony Sanchez the Democrat is a
week away from running for a governor in
Texas Tom Golisano governor in a New
York State a second when a wealthy
candidate inundates TV and radio saying
you're a fool and he's he's a blinkin
and you're The Manchurian Candidate
creates a lot of pressure to raise even
more special interest money to respond
or get left behind and finally democracy
requires diversity I don't mean quotas
and exact numbers but suppose there were
a campaign rule that intended or not
discriminated against whim or women or
Latinos or people with kinky hair people
will be outraged and said we have to
eliminate that rule because it's
discriminating intentional or not
against an entire class of people well
as Barry Goldwater of course
conservative republican and republican
nominee for president 1964 said under
the current rules are we saying that
only the rich have brains in this
country or only people who have
influential friends who have money can
be in the Senate close quote because the
current rules favor people to the point
that if the rules don't change we are on
the brink of having a government we're
the only people who run win and serve
are either special interest hustlers
celebrities or self-financing
billionaire's mr. Smith will not be
going to Washington this problem has
been around a long time as I
but it's peeking in interest now forth
because of three epic developments that
I track in our book selling out first is
the corporate money scandals of 2002
attorney i work with ralph nader in the
1970s it turns out native made a big
mistake he underestimated the power and
corruption of big money in politics um
Enron spends six million dollars for a
reason they're the biggest earliest
contributors to cut the man who became
governor Bush and President Bush so by
the time the scandal of this company was
exposed and eleven congressional
committees began investigating Enron 212
of the 248 members on these
investigating committees had received
money from Enron or its accounting firm
Arthur Andersen in the words of Joan
Claybrook she's the head of one of the
great citizen lobbies in Washington
Public Citizen quote political money
from the N runs and others bought
loopholes exemptions lacks law
enforcement underfunded regulatory
agencies and the presumption that
corporate officials could buy anything
they wanted with shareholders money
whether the corporate scandals once we
get over the extraordinary and
understandable focus on the sniper in
Washington and surrounding areas and
Iraq and the aftermath a year later of
911 once we get back to these subjects
it's not clear whether these scandals
will lead to a species jump in America
as the Progressive Era 100 plus years
ago did as the depression did will it
now remind all those Republicans whose
orthodoxy is always to privatize and
deregulate and tax less I will it remind
people that lazy is not always fair when
it comes to a problems in the
marketplace in the political marketplace
too early to tell but I'll tell you this
when Alan Greenspan the Fed Chairman and
a devotee of ain't Rand support
substantial our corporate reforms and
when george w
rush says we have to have corporate
executive spending more time in jail you
know something big is happening in
America next the mccain-feingold bill
became law this year the first new
campaign finance law in 25 years what it
says is it doesn't affect the amount you
can spend in campaigns but it says
though is people who are giving a
hundred thousand two hundred fifty
thousand dollars individuals
corporations and unions not to
candidates but two parties to spend on
behalf of candidates it's illegal to
federal level now this is like throwing
a 10 foot rope to a drowning swimmer 40
feet offshore it's a start it's not
enough to save the swimmer and so the
next generation of reforms have to go to
what's called hard money direct
contributions which I'll discuss in a
minute before I stop to allow questions
and third the third epic development in
this year is the Supreme Court is about
to revisit the Magna Carter of campaign
finance law the buckley decision of 1976
which said again you can't limit
spending because money is speech well
mccain feingold has some rules that
inhibit spending just before an election
and there's a decision in vermont that
will change america the paste based on
how the supreme court rules the state of
Vermont ignored Buckley and said whether
or not money to a candidate buys his or
her vote is arguable but what's not
arguable is that advised access to a
member you give you get the meeting as
the lobbyists said you don't give you
don't get the meeting everybody would
agree to that if given a polygraph test
and a truth serum and that is corrupt
and so we're going to limit spending in
campaigns in the state of Vermont the
Second Circuit Court of Appeals in New
York State in New York sustain the
Vermont law to 21 now that Court is
reconsidering its decision but so far
they sustain that law if the Supreme
Court upholds of Vermont
all over America laws will be passed
stopping jon corzine Tony Sanchez
Michael Bloomberg from spending their
own money in elections it will level the
playing field no more 20 million dollar
Senate races 60 million dollar a 70
million dollar a mayor's races in other
words the 200 year long movement to make
sure that citizens speak louder than
contributors is coming to a culminating
instant we are in what Bill Moyers that
brilliant social commentator is called a
teachable moment let me conclude because
I don't want to take much more than 30
minutes in what happens next there are
two problems with changing the money
game in state capitals and in Washington
in Washington well very few people are
really expert on a rock or on
prescription drugs out of 535 elected
members 535 are expert at campaign
finance rules because each had to know
the rules navigate them in order to get
into office so to change the rules which
by definition the people voting on the
rules succeeded at is pretty hard second
as much as a regulated business interest
don't like the mutual shake down and are
weary of getting ten calls a day to go
to fundraisers they like less apparently
getting taxed or regulated in ways they
think is ideologically or economically
onerous and so to actually change the
system might require a candidate running
for president on the platform of
systemic campaign finance reform like
John McCain did in two thousand he came
close he almost beat a man who outspent
him 70 million 27 million but if anyone
runs in the Democratic Republican
primaries and becomes president like
Ronald Reagan and George W Bush said I
one and my mandate is for lower taxes on
the wealthy and you got to give it to me
and the kind
did a new president could say I ran to
clean up the cesspool of money the
golden rule of politics in Washington he
who has the gold rules give me what I
want uh and or you need simultaneously
two or three more two or three more
enron and worldcom Zand global crossings
I don't know why we need more scandals
and they will happen you would have
thought 2002 it would be enough you see
the problem is not bad people doing bad
things I'll tell you the people who run
and serve in high office are so much
more honorable and hardworking than the
public ISM credit for the problem is we
have a bad system which literally
coerces good people to raise bad money
with strings attached because if you
don't the person who's running against
you certainly is doing it hence the arms
race analogy for changes would totally
change the way people run serve run win
and serve and totally change American
democracy first you need public matching
funds for small gifts this is not pie in
the sky we have it in the state of Maine
in the state of Arizona New York City
small gift is matched by the public
treasury public treasury I'm spending my
taxpayer money for someone I don't like
what's better to have a person winning
because 20 people each gave him or her
hypothetically a million dollars so
those 20 people own the elected official
or if you have 20,000 people my math may
be off each giving the equivalent of a
hundred dollars if millions of taxpayers
give a couple of bucks apiece then all
taxpayers own the elected official not
just some hence public matching funds oh
gee isn't that expensive nationally
because five hundred million dollars a
year it's more money than Alana and I
have the current private system of
financing costs over fifty billion
dollars
year by one really good estimate in
terms of tax loopholes bailouts of the
companies who get laws enacted that they
wouldn't deserve but for the thumb of
money on the scale of decision second we
need spending caps in elections I tell
you if Pat Buchanan ran against Franklin
Delano Roosevelt and Buchanan spent 100
million and Roosevelt spent a hundred
thousand Buchanan would win and would
brag the people have spoken we have to
have ceilings low ceilings and high
floors so people will win more on merit
than money third the federal election
omission is compiled of comprised of
five people historically usually
political hacks having worked for the
Republican or Democratic parties and
they're they're not to be watchdogs but
lap dogs over the Congress that picks
them in effect the president names them
but the president can't do it without
the okay have senior members of the
Congress and instead Fred Wertheimer
performative common cause now democracy
21 has a proposal as do others I like
the idea of retired judges who are over
70 who may have started out as a
Republican or Democrat everybody's
something but after they've served in
the judiciary if they've retired take
three out of a panel of dozens of
retired judges to run the Federal
Election Commission because they're not
going to be ruling in ways that help
their colleagues get reelected because
they're already a jurists and finally we
need free or discounted TV in Western
Europe democracies provide free
television time to candidates to reach
the public in America in the nineteen
thirty three and four Federal
Communication acts we declared in assets
socialism over the airwaves the public
owns the airwaves because it's a scarce
medium why the hell do we allow private
companies to acquire for free these
public franchises and then charge public
candidates two-thirds in effect of there
campaign treasuries in order to pay them
as toll takers to get to the voters on
the other side um Bill Bradley when
running for the Senate once said that he
feels his entire time is spent
fundraising to turn money from donors
over to broadcasters so he can advertise
and reach people finally is this pie in
the sky these recommendations let me say
that a little over a decade ago
apartheid seemed eternal the cold war
seemed inevitable each collapsed
reforming campaign finance laws which
has been done in the states in the city
I mentioned are certainly easier to
accomplish than ending apartheid in
South Africa or the cold war around the
world only apologists for the status quo
could possibly argue that it's really
okay in a democracy 4.1 % to dictate
policy to the other ninety-nine point
nine percent in effect for only the rich
or the owned to win office for
candidates to spend two-thirds of their
time raising money so broadcasters can
have a good bottom line history is like
waves lapping at a cliff road french
historian andre see for centuries
nothing happens and then the cliff
collapses thank you very much
um thank you this is intermission the
second half of my lecture will begin
momentarily not I wouldn't do that to
you let me ask for any questions and I i
I'd ask if people could come to this mic
because a Colombian should be honored as
I am that c-span is here there may be
national over the air or cable channels
that have large audiences but pound for
pound viewer few for view or none has a
more literate interested audience for
books and issues than c-span and so if
you came here and asked you a question
on your parents will see you on national
television and your colleagues can
better hear your question so could i ask
you to say your name your year here and
then ask you a question hi I'm monisha
I'm a first year here I was wondering
what you thought the impact of the
diverse issues and news media is
covering on the current election like
the diversity I think you know the
diversity of the issues of media is
covering given Iraq the sniper rush the
Moscow hostage situation it's a good
question you know a cliche in the news
industry is if it bleeds it leads
therefore our assignment editors on TV
and radio stations bad people know they
operate in a market economy that like
having ratings listeners viewers ads and
so if something extraordinarily
extraordinary happens like the sniper
attack I mean my wife and I would debate
here i am in relatively safe new york
debating would we have sent our children
to high school if we were in Prince
George's County that's a story that's
around the water cooler it's sensational
and it preempts many other policies is
it a co I believe that George Bush
believes we should attack Iraq I believe
he believes that and that it's good for
America it's not a coincidence that
after Hussein has been in office
for 10 years notwithstanding the assault
on him justifiably so a decade ago by
President Bush's father suddenly after
labor day every day he's prosecuting the
war beating the drums right before this
election but it's working because when a
commander in chief says that a foreign
leader is the equivalent of Hitler it
takes a reasonably courageous public
official like Paul Wellstone to say nope
haven't provided the evidence and
Hussein is bad but Hitler my god he had
the greatest army in Europe in the 30s
he had announced he wanted he had
extraterritorial and anti-semitic
ambitions and to compare him to a despot
whose army is a third what it was a
decade ago who's hemmed in by enemies
who only control the third of his
country is a politically convenient but
it leads the news um and so often
elections it said begin after the World
Series World Series is over over the
Iraq resolutions have been voted out of
Congress thank God the sniper snipers
have been caught and we're going to have
a one-week national election not enough
given that almost never before in
American history has our government and
split so evenly there's never been a
race closer and electoral votes than the
one in two thousand the Supreme Court is
54 in so many decisions the Senate is
5149 and the Congress has a six suites
six-seat majority if you count swing
votes in districts for the Republicans
and so you think this is a great moment
to have a conversation about all the
issues that people vote on let me say
this is being taped eight days before
the election it's not clear whether Iraq
will dominate voters Minds or whether
they'll say a rock is over there
but my real income is down I'm being
laid off I don't have health insurance
whether people's pocketbook immediate
interest in a weakening economy will
speak louder than a rock even though the
headlines have a rock speaking louder
than the economy yes sir hi my name is
Nick and I'm a first year here and as a
Californian planning to vote in my first
election next week and frustrated by
being stuck picking between two
obviously very big spending candidates
just curious the solutions you proposed
at the end of your lecture you know
where where's the where does the common
voter come into play and where you know
it's all it's all up on up here and
we're down here and what are you well in
the state of California you have two
candidates who embody the criticism in
my book selling out Gray Davis is a
Democrat who has raised over 50 million
dollars running for reelection one
California member of Congress said to me
he's a money machine from the early
morning to late night on everything is
calculated to raise money but I'd vote
for great David sapphire in California
but he is the embodiment of he says that
all his large donors are friends of his
because he spends so much of his time
getting to know them lunching with them
asking that he had a meeting with a big
union about a year ago in the middle of
a policy meeting he said listen I really
need a million dollars from you guys a
million dollars they gasped the meeting
went on but it was probably a different
meeting after he said that and that's
wrong and I say that as a Democrat he's
running against the man named Bill Simon
who's the son of a famous Republican
entrepreneur and he's a wealthy
individual and he is spending his own
money he's self financing in his race
and so if you're asking how the average
voter comes in first California now
because it's such a large state and
because the media markets are so
expensive
candidates don't campaign anymore they
hardly have free media events to get on
the news because news stations don't
like covering politics and they know if
they don't cover them it creates a
greater demand for advertising time so
they'll buy more time and so basically
you raise money or you spend your own
money and ads and that's the campaign
California voters were so disgusted by
this that there was a referendum
recently that said enough and starting
after this election I know the New York
laws but not the numbers in California
there are California there were no
limits to what you could give for
Congress starting November sixth you
can't give a member more than two
thousand dollars in a primary for mayor
in New York you can't get more than 4500
dollars in California he give one
hundred thousand dollars there was no
limit now there's going to be a limit on
what you can contribute and so the
system will start to slightly calm down
but until there's a spending limit there
will be a contribution limit you can't
give a candidate more than X but until
there's a spending ceiling you'll have
these arms race cut type campaigns where
bill simon says he has to spend his own
money because Gray Davis is the
incumbent to get more well-known Gray
Davis says he has to spend he has to
raise a special interest money because
bill simon is spending all his own money
and each user's the other as an excuse
to build up their financial missiles and
eventually a system remember the bather
in hot water it got so hot that
California California's were just
disgusted when rivers caught fire the
Cuyahoga River in Ohio caught fire in
the late 60s it led to Earth Day and the
creation of the Environmental Protection
Agency our system is catching fire and
eventually it will collapse or change
there's no other options it's slightly
changing in California not in time for
this election and we'll see if the
change can occur and the National
Congress at is it as it is occurring
around the states hi my name is Justin
I'm a first-year law student and raise
your hand if you if your first-year
students
put your hands down what have what
corruption happens to everybody after
the first year i've heard of the senior
year slump but a sophomore junior and
senior year slop is it unless maybe
Columbia only has one year of college
please a lawsuit we've actually read
buckley versus vallejo already but you
read Buckley vallejo yeah you're gonna
go to law school i am in law school oh
your first year student a collage of
loss cos theta oh okay I also actually
almost worked for you but anyway in the
1970s very influential expensively
well-financed conservative people got
together and they developed a group of
organizations the Christian Coalition
the south eastern Pacific Legal groups
The Federalist Society amongst many
other groups that were very well
financed very well-connected and these
they did not go through the traditional
sort of finance system to get their
political groups known but they they
went in front of school boards they they
went in front of judges and they change
the law totally absent the the system
you're talking about now with the same
uses of well-financed money from large
contributors and even if we get some of
the great you know ideas that you've had
in this given in this lecture how are we
going to stop people from subverting
their views on the general populace in
that way because in Kansas right now I
think only recently I mean because of
what they've done from the school
board's think they have only taught
evolution and this year and they're only
taking as a sort of Looney theory even
now so first let me say because of time
constraints it we're under the three
people waiting should ask questions and
I'll try to limit my answers to get
everyone in please stay it is the
American Way if private people organize
and spend money to advance their point
of view and you can do it philanthropic
Lee if you're not partisan you can get a
tax-exempt status so gifts are
deductible so long as you don't campaign
for candidates and that's the battle of
ideas that's been in America from the
Whigs and the
factories in the Federalist to now it is
true that a business spends money and
labor spends money i remember i did a
firing line show with Bill Buckley and
he got to draft the question that we
would debate do unions have too much
power was his question yeah I said yeah
business packs out spend labor packs 17
21 yeah does labor have too much
political power come on business has
more money and so they Richard scafe
will give huge monies to the Heritage
Foundation and the American Enterprise
Institute and the Manhattan Institute
and they'll have more money are
progressives Democrats have more people
out registered Republicans and that's
the battle in this country it's a battle
of ideas so private spending about ideas
is going to keep going you can't limit
it and you shouldn't we have a First
Amendment but when you run for public
office it's fine you can't change other
variables often variables are bigger
than money a candidates looks
personality ideology to Democrats or
Republicans predominated in that
district what's the hot issue that year
you can't change that you wouldn't want
to but you can regulate the spigot of
money in public elections its
constitutional we've done it but that
doesn't affect what you're saying one
last thing you said the federal society
which is a conservative group of law
lawyers and law scholars in law students
well the American constitutional society
is that you have a chapter here at
Columbia you're the one L rep is a group
of more progressive law students it's
now it's 60 law schools I lecture at NYU
Law School we just started one there you
have one of Columbia uh that's the
multiplicity of tongues tongues as judge
learned hand used in an appropriate
phrase that is the First Amendment thank
you very much Justin I my name is Adam
questioner I'm a senior
you said just now talking about the
prospects for campaign finance reform
you compared the system to apartheid
South Africa and also the Cold War
that's a very that's a morally repugnant
system and also a politically deplorable
system but there are people who
sympathize with Buckley and who think
that campaign money is in fact speech so
do you mean the people don't see it here
perhaps as in such a polarized way as
they saw first long time I think you
understood that my references to
apartheid and the Cold War where those
things seemed immutable and then changed
and so money and politics seems eternal
but can also change it wasn't that money
is as evil as apartheid and remember I
said that it's not the candidates who
are evil people but the system forces
good people to do bad things does
everyone agree with me know his wife why
would I write a book selling out if
everybody agreed with the thesis before
I can't I'd love to debate George will
about this he's as smart as they come
for the other side he's never run for
office George will got to where he is on
this week with George Stephanopoulos and
his columns because of pure skill what
if one morning he walked into his office
and his editor said George listen I'm
sorry but I jill smith has your job over
you you know she gave 100 million
dollars to the paper you go excuse me
I've been here you know I've done well
I'm a good rider yeah but you know it's
her money money is speech he would like
you know he said oh no that's different
oh really it's not as bad as the current
system because the money is buying not a
column we can live but office an office
is um uh justice Stevens wrote after the
Buckley case that money is property of
course it's by the way if money were
speech why are there laws against
bribery hi mr. congressman I'll give you
ten thousand dollars if you vote for my
interest not
a crime it just speech come on what's
the harm in asking you're not a lot of
election year within a hundred feet of a
polling place no one contest that you
can give a hundred decibelle speech
through a loudspeaker in 3 a.m. and a
residential community no one disputes
that that's what's called time place and
manner restrictions it doesn't go to the
content of the speech you can't stop a
speech that is pro or anti Israel but
you can stop any speech pro or anti
Israel if it's too loud in the middle of
the night well I think if you can stop
hundred decibelle speeches you should be
able to effect hundred decibelle
donations which have a bigger set now
that's my point of view I believe
Buckley v Valeo will be overturned I
just don't know whether it's this year
or in 20 years right now if we think
about it it's laughable there was a time
when women couldn't vote and now of
course women can vote it's regarded as
this actually occurred in this country
there will be a time when it will be
looked on as utterly laughable that
billionaires could buy office and it was
permitted under the rubric that his
hundredth million-dollar assured his
speech even if it drowned out the speech
of everybody else it'll be ridiculous
but that's why we have lawyers thank you
hello I'm Paul Morden I'm senior I'm
sorry Paul Paul yes sir yeah I remember
last year in your concession speech to
Michael Bloomberg you didn't mention
that um he had outspent yo great John
you mentioned again tonight um but the
general television commentary about the
election to deal with the the fact that
he was so had spent hundreds about a
hundred dollars per voter um but it also
mentioned what many found to be severe
mistakes near campaign the devices
campaign you ran against Freddy Ferrer
during the run offs
um your inability to reach out to voters
who are Avila income bracket or certain
minorities so I'm just curious if you
could talk about the other reasons why
you're feeling my lost I don't want to
take up time about an individual
election I'm trying to talk generally
and Michael Bloomberg got more votes he
won he serves and as you remember I said
money is not disqualifying from John
Kennedy to Michael Bloomberg and he's
doing a good job um I actually have no
idea what you're talking about about not
reaching out to lower-income minorities
I started the campaign endorsed by Mayor
David Dinkins Russell Simmons the now
the democratic state chairman is African
American named Danny Farrell and and so
I've been to 150 black churches i sued
Rudy Giuliani twice on police misconduct
and won twice so I stuck my neck out on
the hottest button racial issues and the
african-american community voted for me
seventy-five percent in the general
election and so I won't Chronicle the
things i wish i had done differently but
i think it's fair to say that a very
smart businessman like michael bloomberg
did not spend 74 million dollars because
he thought he didn't have to and I
believe in five years or in 50 years if
you or your grandchildren study
campaigns and choose to study the
mayoral election of 2001 two numbers
will leap out not did I run this ad or
that ad that's the trees the forests are
two numbers 911 and 74 million dollars I
had a these are two world-shattering
events the greatest catastrophe in
American history happened on primary day
if I'd handed that in as a treatment for
a novel I would be laughed at
simultaneous with the most money ever
spent and the to change things I think
most people would say but i'll leave it
to more objective people to parse out
exactly what happened
my name is Rosie Barry I'm a graduate
student over the health sciences campus
you ended on a somewhat optimistic note
and that kind of surprises me especially
having dealt with student apathy and
general apathy when it comes to
political issues and using the current
Iraq protests across the country and
across the world do you think that if
the government does change its opinion
or it stands as it stands right now will
it be because of actual involvement of
the people or will be more monetarily
related that's a good question I am not
smart enough I are Leah said that I
believe that President Bush believes
it's in the national interest of this
country to have a pre-emptive if
necessary unilateral attack on a power
that is nearing nuclear capacity I
believe he believes that it's also true
that if we went to war prevailed quickly
and had a Douglas MacArthur a type
administration overseeing a rock as we
had over Japan that we would then be in
control of their oil fields now some
people think that financial motivation
which was openly among the reasons we
attacked a rock after they went into
Kuwait a decade ago and we were right to
do it I don't think that's the major
motivation but could people are arguing
you played a role now you said I ended
on an optimistic note but what about
public protest about Iraq and those are
two different things I'm optimistic
because I'm a pathological optimist I
don't know the alternative no one is
smart enough to be a pessimist is the
thing I say every morning I getting
discouraged gets you nowhere um and
democracy for all its flaws has this
great capacity for self correction you
know from Dred Scott to brownvboard from
women not voting to the 19th amendment
to pay equity laws we eventually get it
right below could take a while on Iraq I
am really worried that a small clique of
administration officials Bush Cheney and
Rumsfeld
without asking the Joint Chiefs who were
originally privately against invading
Iraq without asking the Congress when
Republican leaders like Chuck Hagel who
was in Vietnam Richard Lugar the Past
Chair of Foreign Relations generals any
the ambassador to the Middle East for
President Bush we're all against going
in I just think this is undemocratic in
terms of they decided they're going to
do this for ideological for security or
political reasons and damn the torpedoes
now they got two resolutions through
Congress because right before an
election forgive me a lot of Democrats
are scared to take on a
commander-in-chief saying there's a
threat to America it's hard a few have
frankly this is speculative if the vote
had occurred in january of 03 rather
than october of 02 it might not have
been enacted because they wouldn't have
had the imminence of the election
hovering over them sometimes this
administration will change its mind for
political reasons like any
administration so President Bush runs on
free trade and then in slaps on steel
tariffs in order to win Ohio and
Pennsylvania in 2004 a direct
contradiction of his philosophy for pure
political reasons and that he's not
unique I will they change their mind on
a rock if enough people speak out I
doubt it because they seem zealous in a
way I've never seen before but the
public support for this possible war
we're not at it yet is very narrow and I
think will collapse if it goes poorly
because we've always attacked with from
the moral high ground after Pearl Harbor
after Kuwait after al-qaeda in
Afghanistan and 911 hot pursuit in
military parlance has never included
thinking who are evil regimes in their
countries that we think might hurt us in
the future and I think we should take
them out for
first this is a level of of actually
remember the word imperialism was a
buzzword in the 60s raise your hand if
you were born in the 60s but now the
arrogance of we are militarily superior
but to tell the world that and that will
attack any regime approaching
challenging us is breathtaking you might
think it but to say it could inspire a
next generation of terrorists in the
Muslim world of the lights we've never
seen so I personally disagree with
what's happening and public opinion
eventually 57,000 lives later change the
tide in Vietnam and ideally will change
the tide before we make another mistake
last question hi my name is San Kim I'm
a freshman you talked about two kinds of
wealthy candidates the self financed and
the fundraisers and it seems that you
were saying that the the wealthy
self-financed find candidates were free
of the hoops I had to jump all the I
mean changing their their views on
issues based on the based on the special
interest rate to please and also I mean
the time they spend on fundraising in
general and do you hold that it is more
advantageous for the candidate to be
self financed and sort of fundraisers or
and going further with that do you think
it's advantageous for the voter to vote
for the self financed and sort of the
fundraiser if you're giving me the
Hobson's choice of either or either
someone who's bought by special
interests or is so rich they can ignore
anything I choose not to answer because
selling out and our self correcting
democracy permits the New York City
campaign finance lord the main campaign
finance loan the Arizona campaign
finance alone so many others we're you
public funds so everybody owns the
candidate not some you have spending
ceilings so you
bye you have to earn it um I try to
explain both sides that a tom golisano
New York State is approaching twenty
five percent by arguing nobody owns me
and I can say what I think that's great
unless you think some weird things and
the the problem with it as I indicated
is that there are rules which led to
fewer no African uh there's a Supreme
Court decision called yick whoa and in
the late 1940s a state of California was
hostile to Japanese immigrants and
Chinese immigrants and they had a rule
you couldn't hang your laundry on
clothes hangers in your backyard now
that may seem like just they don't know
visual pollution rule only Chinese and
Japanese recent arrivals were hanging
their laundry in such a fashion and the
court said it was a in effect
discrimination are based on a race the
current rules make it harder for
minorities to run and win because they
don't have the old boys network they're
not yet billionaires and let me conclude
with the state of New Jersey I know like
and would vote for Jon Corzine who is
the senator and frank Lautenberg who i
believe is about to be the senator
they're fine men to both
multimillionaires what are students of
your age who live in New Jersey who are
interested in public affairs going to
think as you approached considering
running for office you realize that
apparently in the state of New Jersey
you can't run and win for the Senate
unless you're a multimillionaire my son
is a freshman at Cornell and he told me
this week that he overheard a
conversation where students were talking
about government and one student said to
another yeah really interested in
government but I intend to do a Corzine
the others didn't said what's that he
said I'm going to get wealthy and then
run
I have problems with that there are
alternatives to the special interest or
the billionaire candidates I believe our
country is going to work its way out to
get their protest about Iraq and
eventually enter public life and do what
you can to change the money game I want
to see women and men of talent like you
serving in office rather than being the
silent silent casualties of a system
that has led to tax cuts for the wealthy
large classes for the poor all in the
name that money is speech I know we can
do better than that and I really
appreciate that you've all come tonight
to Columbia thank you very much mark
Greene is currently a distinguished
visiting lecturer at the New York
University School of Law selling out how
big corporate money buys elections Rams
through legislation and betrays our
democracy is published by Regan books on
the web at HarperCollins com